[Music]
last night RuPaul stopped by The Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon ahead of
hosting Saturday Night Live this weekend
and brew made it clear he's not just any
drag queen
he's the queen of drag this is the first
time a drag queen has ever been put on
the Queen Queen I am the queen of drag
[Applause]
apologize
oh I'm embarrassed I'm sorry I know you
should be I'm gonna kill your car wash
did you see Jimmy's face when he thought
he may have said something wrong - Maru
hilarious you also admitted that his
favorite thing to do wherever he goes is
to play dirty charades and the two
played around last night all right here
we go
movie three words and you know this
means total concept right okay yeah
total concept all right okay all right
okay here we go
yep set Saturday Night Fever turn a
fever the third word
[Applause]
is that just me or does Ruth seem to be
having a lot more fun than usual in this
interview
I love seeing him like this and with
season 12 of RuPaul's Drag Race
premiering later this month
rooo explained why people connect to the
show honestly I think it has to do with
the tenacity of the human spirit
everybody wants to root for the underdog
and these kids have come from homes what
a mom and a daddy have thrown them out
but they said you know what mama you
know what daddy F y'all you do you daddy
you do you I'm gonna do me I'm a grown
root rot pull root Paul drag to drag
race and I'm gonna do my thing and you
know f y'all look she's not on the cover
of a magazine rue also brought along a
sneak peek at the season 12 premiere
featuring Nicki Minaj welcome to the
main stage of Nicki Minaj's drag race
I'm so glad you're here Young Money in
the house
[Applause]
her anaconda do Michelle visage you
should know what my anaconda do style
superstar Carson Kressley you ready I'm
ready to pound the alarm even though
I've never counted anything in my life
not yet now while we're on the topic of
drag race yesterday et Canada's fabulous
host cheryl hickey caught up with Ross
Matthews who told her why the 12th
season is his favorite season 12 is I
think it's my favorite season ever yeah
why because these queens are so good you
know the show's been on about 11 years
and a lot of these queens are in their
early 20s they've grown up in a world
with RuPaul's Drag Race on the air which
is so great so great so they have been
inspired by the show and now they're
reinventing it by coming on it you know
and there's not a clunker in the bunch
there's not a clunker you can't refer to
this you can't do that that's very nice
I'm not insinuating there have been
clunkers I'm just saying this year there
are no clunker so who are you rooting
for on season 12 of drag race are you
gonna watch RuPaul host SNL this weekend
I can't wait do you agree that RuPaul is
the queen of drag let me know in the
comments below
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos